so my sicko it's currently on the
version 8.0 point 11 the thing is they
been the version before that the release
candidate was eight point zero point
four they skipped again seven numbers
and put it on eight point zero four 11
and the are we doing yet about this talk
it's like we always have this
inferiority syndrome like because we use
my sick oh it's not a good enough
database to do stuff you start doing
your Mexico and then you changed post
grades because you're gonna have more
features there and I can't argue
impossible is great for a lot of stuff
where my sickle is getting there is
getting a lot of new cool features and
allowing the growth of a lot of
companies to be successful because of it
so when it was created it was created to
handle small cases from ten million to
100 million rows of data or a hundred
megabytes for for table now supports
terabyte science databases on them on
our managed service on Google we support
up to 10 terabytes on your database on a
single database and support secure
standards as us sequel 2016 with the
JSON RFC so we supports Jason but
however some stuff is still from 2003
just got implemented like window
functions and cities now what can we go
from here
what can we grow up mastico can grow and
learn from other other databases there
is one feature I don't know who uses
post occurs here but like it's called
partial index and or conditional index
you can create an index on a database
conditionally like I only index these
values if they are higher than 11 for
instance that's a cool feature that
could be used for a lot of cases but
let's hope that in the future they just
copy that up
so what happened to 6 & 7 maybe they got
inspired by our language and skipped
versions but as far as I know they had
their enterprise product called the NDB
cluster and then the big cluster was
higher version 6 and higher version 7
and with the version 8
they are only find all the versions
together of the Indy be closer with the
Mexico community version so that's why
it goes straight from 5-7 to 8 the
topics topics of this talk is going to
be new defaults and variables I'm going
to talk about I know DB performance what
our window functions in common table
expressions and in the end I have other
tiny bits of new features they are
inserted in the news the new version so
the new defaults and verbals it's who
here had trouble with charset like
everybody yeah so good news is on 5 7
you had watching one Swedish case is
sensitive of Eriko correctly and now
it's 8.0 it's utf-8 and before which
means that a 4 bytes per character on
the utf-8 format and it means that you
can have mathematical equations emojis
and even languages that you don't even
think that exists and like transcripts
toric transcripts instead around the
database without any issue
so the sure set defines how the data is
going to be stored while the collation
defines how the data is going to be
compared and the fall collisional it's
this ugly thing and it just means you
have 9.0 support for utf-8 and I know
that it's on 10 right now it have 8 or
11 already but when they started the
development of my secret 9 was the most
recent one that they had accidentally
sensitive in case insensitive there was
a bug before each FM utf-8 in before you
can use on five seven but if you use one
of the
to collations here you can have a bug
where if you use the sushi emoji in the
the beer image they're equals
they're considered equals so we don't
have that bug anymore all of the
following variables binary logging is
enabled by default so if you need to do
a pony time recovery or go back and go
back in time or the replication it's
kind of a tease
setting up for you and there is a new
plug-in of Education it doesn't use uses
shot to using SSL Certificates and it's
more more secure way of accessing your
database through a new layer of security
but you still can use the load way for
education purposes if you still need it
there is military default value now for
timestamp for instance you could create
a table timestamp default empty but say
that's not know and then before would
insert sewers or zeros as a timestamp or
a date or zero also as a date now it
gives you an error and you need to have
a default if you're using that now and
there is a new variable if you have a
dedicated server don't need to figure
out how to configure the buffer size the
log file the flush method you just say
that's dedicated server and all these
variables are going to get configured
dynamically for you on the my city of
Mexico configuration file there is a new
thing that my sicko is doing that no
other database in the world is doing and
it's regarding to I know to be its
transaction scheduling as we call it's a
new algorithm that they're using based
on I forgot a college but based on a
paper a professor and their their main T
came up with the paper and they
implemented it on my sequel so routinely
you have a database and you usually have
a first-in first-out transaction
architecture so transaction B is only
going to happen if transaction a happens
in B only happens if after a and C only
after be and that's start to finish
that's usually first thing first out
normal transaction for databases now
they are using Katz what they call cuts
stands for contention and where
transaction scheduling it's a big name
and I'm sorry for my join I try to do
illustrate how what's going on but now
the best technology that I have it's
like I'm gonna assume the most people
knows how an airport works and you have
TSA in the u.s. you have TSA where you
need to go through security and nobody
in every plane is um has a gate that
that's that's assigned to it if it
everybody takes too long to take on of
the plane the gates not free so no one
else can use the gate so no other
passengers can come no other flights can
go that's more or less what's happening
here so the the Mexico is taking care of
the the process of receiving people and
administering the gates so you can have
the most amount of gates free let's say
so most planes can come and go faster
that's the best analogy it doesn't
matter who came first or not it's it's
gonna figure out based on the algorithm
that they they develop which transaction
gets you executed first and then doesn't
mean it's and that's necessarily the
same order so that's the performance
only changes after that it and it starts
to kick in and 32 transactions per
second and you see that on on cats a the
higher is the better so you can have
more clients and on FIFO you only have
like I have a third of it or something
like it
and the same thing is regarding latency
because how many depending on how many
transactions you're having on your on
your database the more timing is gonna
take to respond to you and the latency
here is way lower five times over on the
new algorithm that they are using on my
Seco 8 so if you have a like a high
throughput high highly access database
that's gonna kick in and it's gonna make
things faster without having to scale
vertically your database in Access this
one makes me happy who here had to
create an index in took hours and hours
and hours to do it everybody so I'm
having an example I went to I don't know
if you know
Cagle ka g GL e.com it has like a lot of
open data so I got all the Simpsons
lines of all the episodes and I decided
to play around with with that to play
with the indexes so I have ID I have
number and like other other fields and
I'm gonna play with word count I'm gonna
create what we call invisible indexes
and like why the hell do I want an
invisible index you're gonna ask well
let's say there is a problem with
indexes that you can have too many or
you can have to feel if you have too
many the writes are really slow and if
you have to feel the reads are really
slow so if you have too many rights you
may want to see like disable that index
to see if the performance that got
better on your right and then drop it
because it's a operation that takes
hours to be performed it's a copy
operation where it copies the whole
table to do everything again so it's not
used by the optimizer the invisible in
axis it's visible by default when you
create an index but to create the
invisible index it just add the word
invisible Indian
and you can talk with the visibility on
and off and those operations to talk
about the visibility on and off are
quite fast
it doesn't take milliseconds at most and
that it's an example that I have here
selecting all the lines wearing the word
count is higher than 25
that's the query planner for without
with the index the index exists but it
is invisible and it's having skinny
125,000 rows or what I mean the full
table but when the index goes back on I
only scan 6000 rows because I have an
index on the word count so you could see
like is this index being used or not
there are cases where the performance
could go worse or not and that's when
you toggle visibility on and off to know
what what you're gonna do this woman
what's makes me happy that has been like
a complaint that I have been doing since
2015 for the Oracle developer advocate I
was like we don't have the same indexes
because up to five seven and the syntax
of fives have allowed you to have
ascending or descending
when creating but the the documentation
says that in future extensions are being
implemented and they are going through
pores the birthday are ignored so you
could put the sand in there it was not
gonna work it took me days to figure
that out
when I first started using MySQL for me
I was like I wonder how that's the
standing it's not working and that's why
because it was not implemented now we
have it which is good and the thing with
this any nexus is it works backwards -
it's no longer ignoring and first really
creative as a semi so you just you can't
use the same syntax that they would ask
you to use before but they would ignore
and the same syntax of I created then
this index as descending at the index
word count and if you look at the query
planner for the descending order by or
ascending order by their gonna have the
same cost so let me show you here so
that's my table lines that I don't have
the index here so I'm gonna alter table
lines
and it's there if we look again I have
the index here so let me come on let me
go that query select star from lines
where word count higher than 25 order by
word count this one
I created the the index ascending so I'm
going to run the query first with the
same inquiry and then let me put an
explain in here you see the here it's
using the key that I just created and
it's filtering 6000 rows and 100 percent
of it and then what you want you to pay
attention to is this thing the extra
using index condition now if you change
to the ceiling it still uses the index
but it says here backward index scan
what it means it's now before would do a
full table scan to get the sinning now
it just uses the index you already have
no matter if it is ascending or
descending it's so you don't have to
create two types of indexes on your
database if you're doing the two types
of queries there's more cool features we
know functions
who in here knows what they are so we
know functions are also known as
analytical functions they are used on
what we call mostly OLAP databases like
redshift and B query or lab stands for
own analytical processing and usually
they are slow processing you use our
aggregations and that kind of stuff and
we know functions is present on post
requests for instance and now it's
present on MySQL a2 so what they do they
allow you to analyze you have a result
from a select and it will be able to
analyze the result with the Rosa
to have in hand you cannot change the
result you can look at neighboring roads
I can look at the road that what that
was before me and the road that's after
me and have you know that information do
something with it and to you to do that
you need to use a we call a frame it's
like when you're looking at SATA window
and you change angles you're changing
your framing and you're looking over
something and that's when you do our
partition of a window and the partition
behaves like a goodbye it's not a
goodbye but it kind of simulates a good
by itself so example some of window
functions you can add a row number you
can use the Sun and get accumulated some
of how many million viewers the work per
episode in season rank results and look
as I said before as the neighboring rows
with lead and lag so this is also from
The Simpsons
it's an episode stable and I want to be
playing with the episode 8 and million
viewers here then we need to figure that
out here so the episode date for now is
just a simple select bringing the first
10 episodes and if I want to get the
previous episode and the next episode of
that query here so I want to get the
previous that's the date of the previous
that's ID 1 and the next one that's form
ID 2 you use the lead and the lag you
put up the framing which it is the order
by episode date and because the order in
this case is important I need to know
which episode was before and same thing
with that will lead the order by episode
8 also when you look at that that's when
you get as a as a result you get the
previous episode and the next episode as
columns the results that did not change
it did not change what the query is
bringing to you it just added those
columns with the information that you
already had on the result set so if you
look at the color scheme directory
you're gonna see that the current
episode date for for number two which is
red is actually the next episode date on
the first one so you have access through
all of the results from your result site
with episode 8 the breakdown less lag is
a function episode dates the column that
you're getting information that you want
to know what else about how many rows
preceding the partitioning I want and
that the window that you define with
order by in this case here but we are
developers we like joy we like to keep
things simple as possible and we are
repeating here yes ourselves so you're
doing order by episode day twice and
what happens if I do it again I need to
copy again no you don't need that you
have named Windows you can add a name
for a window I named mine dates and I'm
just saying hey use dates here and if I
change the definition updates it's gonna
automatically update the query here
without having to change everywhere else
in the query so I have an example here
there and I want to show you so this is
the query that we just ran I just have a
different name for the window here I'm
calling W episode 8 but it's the same
query and if I run I get the same result
side that I was just showing you all
what I want now I'm gonna add it here I
want to use the rank function should
know what is the order like I have a
season and those episodes which ones are
the most viewed I want you to rank for
me which one was the first which one was
the second most viewed and so on so on
so you rank over and remember that I say
the partition buys like a goodbye is
this is by season I can do a partition
by season
and the order is important because I
want to know which one had the most
million viewers so order by million
viewers listening and let me give you
this a name and let me show you here so
for the first season here season one the
ninth episode of the season has was the
most viewed the second one was the
eleventh and there is a catch here
you're gonna see the nine repeats twice
that's okay
two million view a same amount of
million viewers but then skips to eleven
it doesn't have the time it's just
because since its there's two ways of
doing ranking and to solve that problem
you just used answering and it's gonna
fix it and the ten is there and then
eleventh I could do also the accumulated
part of how much million viewers were
are watching on averse on every season
so I want a partition by season again
that's a big thing don't worry about it
I had today I hope you works so this is
cumulative if you see here the first
ones has study through milling and then
the second one is the sum of the first
with the second and the third one is the
sum of the first choose that's useful
for analytical reports where you're
getting like the accumulated amount like
a shopping cart or how many value you're
generating on your e-commerce for
instance so that's one way of using
another window functions to get
accumulated results and if you can get
to season 2 its recites again because I
said it was by season commentary
expressions are most people think it's
just syntactic sugar for sub-queries
instead of like the problem you use this
of course is because you wrote once if
you need to use it again you need to
write again and common type of
expression allows you to create
something like a temporary table but
it's not a temporary table because you
don't need to create privilege to use it
and you can reference other table
expressions or reference itself because
it can be recursive also and is easier
to read way more easier to read so this
is this the ranker ranked episodes of
the query that I just did before one
it's the same query and I'm going to
show you a filter let's say I want to
get only the first so I have all the
rankings here but I wanna wear the first
the first thing we could say you could
use limit 1 and on the super query I
want all the fifth most watched episode
so normally someone would get a query
here
and do something like this
we're ranking in this case I wanna put
equal to five so all everyone that's
seen here my results at has a ranking of
five but if you look here it's not easy
to read at all it's it gets bigger and
bigger if you have more sub queries to
be doing inner joins that kind of stuff
so there is a special world called with
and you give the name in this case I'm
doing ranked observes and you define how
that table expression is going to look
like it's like a view but not
necessarily so that's our table
expression and if you want to use it if
you wanted to see you just do in the end
the new table you just created that's
bringing everybody in here we're ranking
equal to five again and if you need to
do inner joins in here you can do in
your joints you can create multiple
table expressions if with the same width
and one referencing the other so that
kind of saves time instead of having
those huge blocks of seco queries to be
maintained is easier to maintain
there is also recursive city and this is
the part that I hope I don't lose my job
because I'm going to try to do Fibonacci
using psychic rays so I don't have to
gonna work but let's see so the recipe
is the base query comes first is like
when you do a recursive functions in
your base case is what is my where do I
start and then in the case of the query
you need to continue to get all the
other information which it is with the
Union and the stop condition which will
stop the recursion itself so it's kind
of a function of a function on PHP
instance so I'm gonna open here so I put
the steps in here so I kind of cheated a
bit you still use the width but you say
the recursive part and the name of the
expression of the table that you're
creating and in this case it can receive
like fair it's not parameters but it's
looks like it and again you use the s to
do the definition and now my second step
is the simple case what is the simple
case of Fibonacci studying with one ring
so I just select one I'm going to
actually use recursion live on let me
start with zero as a recursion level
studying is you my first people naughty
number is going to be one my next number
is one and the sequence I'm gonna cast
as a string here because else is gonna
blow up on your minds so this is just if
I select here it's just a simple row now
where the recursion comes from we need
to the Union all you select and what is
the next recursion 11 is going to be
recursion 11 level plus 1 then the
Fibonacci number starts to be the next
number because I'm changing rows and if
you watch it sums the current number
plus the previous so I'll have Fibonacci
number
Plus next number and I'm just
concatenating here so we can see the
what it's gonna look like
sequence if next number but I created
all the Select that's what's going to
happen I'm recursion there is new level
zero one so this is going to be
returning one next number it's one
because it's what I define in here if
you want actually number it's gonna be
the the current Fibonacci number plus an
example which is going to be two
the next number is gonna be true and the
concatenation you're gonna bring 1 comma
1 comma 2 and so on so on but all of
that comes from the Fibonacci itself and
then or stopping condition where I'm
gonna put recursion 11 last night and 10
and in the end remember it's a common
type of expression you're declared but
you need to use it so you need to do
select star from Fibonacci and it should
work it's here I put it everything so
this is the Fibonacci number currently
and the next time is going to be 1 4 4
and if you don't say setup recursion
level and they will occur that are too
long because I limited the short 4 to 5
5 but that's it for the Fibonacci how
are you mentally
okay that's the query in the end that I
created and this is the recursion
recursion call so it's the same query
it's gonna be the slides and this useful
when you have for instance WordPress
where I have categories that have
subcategories
and you it's an hierarch called data and
you want to go through all of that so
instead of doing a loop on your PHP code
you can do a loop whatever inside the
database all right already
instead of going through the code to get
all that information of whose parts of
of whom and that's the base case as the
first line and the recursive query
generated all the other ones other bits
to finish my secret eight has a data
dictionary now which I have something
here ignore there the data dictionary
and atomic DDL so before the data was
stored on my eyes on tables and they
were prone to corruption and getting
problems with synchronization between
what replications
so all that text it's a file structure
that my sicko had before it doesn't
exist anymore everything else is inside
I need to be tables and they are trans
since I need to be is transactional you
can do to an atomic DDL that we call all
of the data is accessible for through
the information schema they which are
views on the data dictionary and like I
see that some people access the
performances schema to know how many
rows a big table has and instead of like
that kind of operation now is gonna be a
hundred a hundred times faster than
would be before because they just change
how the data dictionary works not that
you should do that you shouldn't feel
like it's faster now
so the DDL the ddr stands for data
definition language consistent data
dictionary updates because you can
update the data dictionary storage in
gene operations like I'm changing frying
at the beach my eyes on that kind of
stuff and binary log writes mostly and
now I told you you can have atomic 2dl
who here try like job table 1 comma
table 2 comma table 3 and like
Table two stopped and your job table 1
and table 3 is still there and she got
corrupted that doesn't happen anymore
either all changes happen or none of
them ones gonna happen it doesn't mean
it is transactional that that creates
the creation of tables transaction or
not
it means like they are guarantee you a
Tom atomicity within the database and
let me show you the other bits that I
was here users now can have roles so if
you created a grant for someone you can
multiply that without have it you go
user by user creating you can add
columns instantaneously without having
to wait two days to add a column to your
database cats instead of FIFO as I said
before you can do it JSON partial update
which means you don't need to dis
serialize the JSON do the change and
then serialize again you can do directly
on the database that's the new version
of if the new data it's smaller or equal
to the chase that was already there and
they have better geospatial support for
in axing and generated columns and
better UUID support and you can use my
second out as no Seco if you wish so
they release what they call me psycho
shell or X the X dive a P is for that
put it in here where you can add you can
also use that with PHP and nodejs so
thank you
[Applause]